[موسيقى]
المحل تاسس سنه 1967 بيي كان الشاف بيي
فرنسوه كان شاف كان عمي يشتغل هون بالصاله
معي مع ناكبسون معه كان في يا عمي فوق
بشتغل على الفول وحمص وعلى البارد يعني
وفي بنت عمي
فتح على جميع الاصعده بعدين شوي شوي صار
يشوفوا انه الزبونات عم يتجهوا على
الصحن اليومي صار يركب المنيوه على هوا
الزبونه
بالبيت كله طبخ بتذكرني امي
انا من زمان مش خمسه عشرين سنه 16 سنه
على طول بعمر امك امي ميته الله يرحمهم
عامله مثلا اكل لاني ما بحبها
باكل عندهم اكلوا اكل بيت اكل ام لما
توفيت امها
الاوقات اللبناني
الاجنبي شو بيلبش بنبش على الاكل البيت
بنبش على السعر المدروس على الاشياء
السامبا ما بينبش مثلا على اليوكس
[موسيقى]
بفتره كورونا بتعرفي كركب البلد وسكروا كل
شيء كنت اشتغل بالشركه كنت مدير اداره
وبعدين ما عاد صار في شغل وسكر البلد وما
عاد تزبط معنا يعني
انا بمجال الاكل لاسيما الصاج والبيتزا
والاخبار بحب عندي رغبه
وكنا نعمل هذا الشيء عزف رند يعني نعمل
هيك جروب وناموا كلهم نشجعوا انه ليش ما
هذا الشيء بنستسلم نعرف الناس نحن شو
بنعمل بقى اخذنا القرار
وجينا لهون هلا الناس هون قلنا انتم جايين
وين جايين على منطقه منكوبه وما فيها حياه
وما معروف من بعد انفجار المرفا
كان هذا المحل ما يشبه الخربه يعني مكسر
اخدنا قرار وخلال 25 يوم ضوينا
انه فكره الصاج هو شي قديم
ونحن فعلا عم نشتغل بالاشياء الاصلي وشوي
اورجانيك كونه انا عندي بضايقتي بزرع بعض
الاشياء بدنا البندوق يعني شو في موسم
نزرعه
نحنا مثل كل الناس يعني بس بالنتيجه يعني
الحياه بدها تستمر
دوله الناس من الاخر يعني صرنا قبل كنت
تدفع حق الشغله
10,000 ليره اليوم انت صرت عارف حالك انه
هيدي سعره هالقدونس عم تستوعب عم يعني خلص
ايديولوجيا البشر هون بلبنان استوعبوا انه
رايحين على دوله الاشياء
ويعني بدنا نستمر متل ايتمز او اي سلعه
بالبلد عم تنشغل او عم تنباع
[موسيقى]
فتحنا هذا المحل
على هذا يعني على الكل سنه 2007 حبيت اعمل
هذا
شو بطلع على راسك قنينه ما عم بتلاقيها
اكثر شيء مختلطين بالقصص الامانه
النادره احنا ما كنا يعني مقريرين انه
مزبوط بدنا نعمل هذا الكونسر بس هو السوق
بجرك شوف العالم شو بدها ونحنا عم ننب
العالم
نحن بلبنان اكثر شيء مشهورين
وبالعرق يعني لا يوضع
نحن اكثر عالم تاذنها
[موسيقى]
هون احنا هون هذا ما حدا كان هون
القنينه بس تقلب تنكسر بتروح خلص
بس مثلا اللي عنده تنفترض ما بعرف شو وقع
على الارض بحطه على الرف ببيعه عادي نحن
خسرنا 80% من ضغطنا يعني اكتر من 90 الف
دولار انا راحوا هيك بخمس ثواني انا من
بعد ما كنت معي مصاري ومرتاح بعيشتي
ومعيدين صرت مبطل معي مصاري صرت مديون
وبطلت مرتاح بعيشتي
كيف كفيت هيني كثير اول شيء انا لبناني
بتعرف اللبناني دغري بقوم
[موسيقى]